to the north and west of Ireland's
county donegal is windswept Tory island
surrounded by the hungry waves of the
Atlantic
less than 200 people live here including
Ireland's last and only King a tradition
that goes back 1,400 years and my name
is Patsy dad Rogers the king of Turia's
to say and you're very welcome to Tory
Island as king of the island Patsy's
role is mostly symbolic in the sixth
century a visiting Saint created the
role in order to unify the Islanders in
defense of pirates but Patsy is very
proud of his islands rich heritage we
have our own Gaelic language everyone
speaks Gaelic on the island we have a
very strong culture we are session errs
Patsy's duties as king or few but he
takes his role as Island ambassador very
seriously
he becomes from various parts of the
world from a number of countries to meet
me under see me on the island and to
talk to me
when I accepted that simple honor of the
king I thought it would never come to
what it did come to now that's quite
serious now
of the roughly 150 people who live on
Tory Island many are over 65 years old
and the island struggles for tourism and
help from the mainland I'm almost 70
many are over 70 and the Islanders not
got to really depend on that type of age
you know as much as we'd like to
they would like to see the population of
the island growing and also a few jobs
to teenagers and the island to start
swinging again
what they died eight and knowing patsy
may be the only Irish king but his hope
is that he won't be the last
when I'm on my dying bed hopefully
before that somebody will come up and
offer protect the honor of the king of
the Alec yes Donnie